you will have seen the words of Dimitri
Pasco of the spokesman for Vladimir
Putin yesterday first and foremost your
reaction to what he said to Mark Austin
uh yeah firstly well done for Sky to
securing that interview it was important
for us to hear the diet of news that the
Russian people uh are experiencing uh we
as you reported must brace ourselves I
think for more Horrors to be revealed uh
more war crimes be exposed as Russian
troops uh withdraw but the spokesperson
Dimitri peskov was very very clear this
is far from over and there is another
dark chapter soon to follow so there's
some big questions for NATO and the West
our confidence is no doubt building uh
we're improving on our decision making
to take risk but I make it very very
clear there's so much more we need to do
we continue to leave Ukraine to do all
the heavy uh lifting we need to provide
greater weapon systems and stop having
simply Daft arguments about whether
weapon systems are indeed defensive or
offensive what's going to happen next as
far as I can see it is a focus on Russia
in the Don Bass region and indeed in
Odessa and Odessa is a critical port in
the South if that falls Ukraine will
become landlocked the vital grain
exports that we all depend on will not
be able to get out but more importantly
Putin will be able to declare a win what
we should take away from that peskov
interview is the fact that Putin is very
secure in his job he's not scared of any
war crimes he's not scared of breaching
the Geneva conventions in fact he's
taken advantage of the West timidity
we've given him space to conduct these
Horrors and that needs to stop
if Mr Elwood and certainly I'm not
disagreeing with you there's plenty of
evidence that Vladimir Putin is uh is no
fan of the Geneva Convention but if
there is a risk of him you know breaking
once again the Geneva Convention is this
the time for Britain and others to
therefore be supplying that that heavier
those heavier armaments those heavier
Munitions that ukrainians are calling
out for I mean the reason we didn't up
until this point the stated reason was
well there were concerns about Russia
declaring us becoming a party to the war
itself
you know we need to have better
confidence and understanding of the
escalatory ladder as we did during the
Cold War what we can do in the theater
of operations in Ukraine to support
Ukraine aware that we need to control
this and not as people are too worried
about uh causing World War III but we've
been too easily spooked by the Kremlin
rhetoric Britain has done more I have to
say than most other countries then I
think in nearly every other country
firstly prior to the invasion and then
after the invasion as well but because
NATO itself won't give the blessing
won't endorse uh greater Hardware to be
put in we're now seeing a public bidding
war between between countries like the
Slovak Republic putting in the the tanks
uh Poland putting Mig aircraft Australia
now sending an APC and indeed Britain as
well this shouldn't be done in the
public gaze this should be quietly uh
done behind the scenes understanding the
need of the Ukrainian people getting the
equipment getting the ammunition getting
that across we're doing enough right now
to ensure that Ukraine doesn't lose but
not enough to ensure that they win let's
get on with this let's be more robust in
standing up to Russia in Ukraine and
let's focus on what they need to protect
Odessa they need Harpoon missile systems
uh if we were very bold we would send an
international Maritime NATO task force
to patrol the international waters off
Odessa that would be a statement to
Russia to say we are now taking this
seriously we're going to stand up to you
I mean NATO of course won supernational
organization another is the United
Nations and yeah Russia has been ejected
from the U.N Human Rights Council but if
you look at the vote there 24 countries
voted against 58 countries abstained
we've had an awful lot in the past
couple of weeks about a Unity of Purpose
with those opposed to what is happening
in Ukraine you look at the figures on a
vote like that and that that kind of
unity of purpose doesn't seem quite as
clear
yes and you're absolutely right to point
to that the success of the sanctions
that it will take a while to bite is the
fact that the entire International
Community has lent into that but that
vote itself did expose many people that
continue to sit on the fence people like
South Africa Brazil India and so forth
we need to work with these countries to
make them understand that this is
against Putin against the regime not
against the Russian people but more
countries can stay United on this the
faster that we're about to move and
support uh Ukraine so it was an
eye-opener and it shows that there's
much work to be done by the
International Community not East Britain
and the United States
we've just been looking at pictures M
from bored Yanka and of course that we
heard from President zielinski yesterday
responding to the the accusations of war
crimes that have taken place in butcher
that we could see even worse even worse
there if such a thing is it is
imaginable just though in terms of the
process of securing a declaration of war
crimes having been committed given that
Russia yeah we'll get from Russia's
disdain for the international criminal
court what Prospect is there
well it's not just the disdain of the
international criminal court they left
it in 2016. so I don't think there's any
chance of getting put in or indeed even
a general let alone a soldier uh to turn
up in The Hague anytime soon that
shouldn't stop us from collecting that
evidence but we need to think of what
new vehicle needs to be created to be
able to hold these people uh to account
because it begs the questions about our
International rules-based order the
reason why both Russia and to some
extent China exactly are able to exploit
our International rules it's become
they've become so rickety they've become
rather wobbly after you know 50 70 years
since they were created after the second
world war the fact that China and Russia
has a veto at the United Nations
security Council shows how impotent
these organizations have become yeah we
now see state-on-state Warfare take
place in Europe there's a lot of
rebuilding to be done
sure but isn't it almost even even
simpler than that we heard from Vladimir
Putin's secretary yesterday the same as
we've heard from their ambassador to the
United Nations when the evidence is put
in front of the Russians clear
compelling evidence prima facie evidence
of war crimes they just say no we didn't
do it and and in circumstances like that
we have to be concerned about their own
limits on their behavior don't they
yes and again this is what's been
exposed by this war because Putin's
disregard or um Russian life itself he
doesn't care about the soldiers that he
loses he's considering the Legacy that
he's trying to create here he wants to
expand Russian influence in the Slavic
Arena of Europe which is why I'm afraid
the penny still hasn't dropped that this
isn't just about Ukraine that we
continue to bench Nate the NATO forces
the most formidable Alliance in the
world as we watch these activities these
atrocities take place in Ukraine it begs
the question what scale of atrocity what
scale of War crime what scale of breach
of Geneva Convention must we witness
before we actually up our grain up our
game and actually move in to support
Ukrainian people in the way that they've
requested
um Mr Norwood what's we have you I I do
want to ask you about um Rishi sunak and
and his wife's non-dom tax status I I I
just wondered I mean I I saw someone
quoted in in the guardian this morning
yeah a totally MP but admittedly one
that was described as a friend of Boris
Johnson saying look at Rishi sunak is
rich as he is richer than increases to
have his wife having non-dom tax status
at a time that he's putting up taxis is
a bad look I'm just wondering your view
on that
every Minister when you enter uh
government has to make a declaration and
that declaration is confirmed to be
legal before you can take up the post so
there's nothing illegal about what's
been done by the chancellor whatsoever
if there are bigger more fundamental
questions about the existence and the of
the non-dom status that is something for
us as a country perhaps in indeed
Parliament to debate but the idea that
we focus on this discussion about uh uh
following the rules that actually
existed at the moment I think is a
distraction for what we need to be
focusing on which is the previous
subject right now of what Britain is
going to do to help and lead other
countries support Ukraine yeah I I do I
do get the point that there are there
are certainly bigger topics around than
than Russia at the same time you know
the conservative party have been in
power since 2010. Lord Ashcroft had to
give up his non-dom status so that he
could sit in the house or continue to
sit in the House of Lords I mean this
has been something that has been
circling around Tory ranks for quite
some time
right and there again you go back to my
point the rules are there if the rules
as a whole need to be changed let's have
that debate but that's away from Rishi
sunak's uh wife that's more to do with
the uh the existence the continuation of
a non-stand status and and the
Privileges that you gain from that in my
view they are out of date they do need
to be reviewed